the Yadavas airport appears almost
deserted here's what it looks like at
the key this is the customs and dispatch
area just a single truck in sight and
here's the building for haulers and
logistics firms but twice a week ships
do doc here today it's the Susan coming
in from Shanghai it's Danish owner
already had most of its cargo offloaded
in Rotterdam just a few containers
remain to be put ashore here at Yad
avisa still it gives the dockworkers
something to do after several days
without any work Michael Anderson is
managing director of the port which
costs a billion euros to construct the
Dane has been involved in the project
from the start but denies that mistakes
have been made effingham the bow and
construction began in 2008 we were told
build as fast as you can because there's
no capacity left especially at play
mahasin but then the economic crisis hit
and there were a lot fewer containers
we're having to cope with that not just
us but our clients to Anderson and his
team had hoped to attract much larger
ships than the Susan tiada visa ships
with Kiehl's that stretch up to 20
meters below the waterline the world's
largest gantry cranes were specially
built here to handle vessels like these
but they prefer to head for nearby
bremerhaven vice or what our problem is
well not our problem but the problem of
the ship owners is that they're not
getting the growth he expected to come
this week there aren't enough containers
for them to want to commit themselves to
another port is open but Germany's most
modern port is popular with tourists
they even come in in the pouring rain
daily and by the busload the struggling
port has turned into a booming tourist
attraction
aleem here after dinner table 13 of us
you buddy Neko six against us um hold on
today there's even a ship here we're
very happy about that but we've got to
move on we have six more buses coming
you know the newport was the great hope
of the people of ill Helms half and some
thirteen percent of its 80,000 residents
are unemployed that's twice the national
average in the heart of the town many
shops stand empty
at City Hall no one feels responsible
for the disaster either mayor andreas
Wagner says he still believes in the
poor project and the prospect of
thousands of new jobs even though yada
visa is heaping up losses every day I
don't ask myself how long it'll stay
afloat the port will come into its own
next year but the port's operators now
realized they'll have to work hard to
attract ships they've hired new
marketing experts to win over clients at
trade fairs and other shipping events as
Mike wanted to be fine oh gosh I
mcmuffin they hope their efforts will
soon bear fruit isn't the equity of long
does it we're very hopeful that an
expansion will occur in the next year
we've received good news from various
ship owners that in future they intend
to serve several ports using villamartin
as a hub for import and export after 16
hours the Susan leaves the RV's airport
heading for Singapore whether more ships
will be docking in Ville Helms half and
next year remains unclear dock workers
perform practice runs to make sure their
skills don't get rusty waiting for ya
des baisers ship to come in